could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
i remember my first away game and i
turned up and i saw hi could you tell me
where the boardroom is and he said dear
you don't understand the director's
wives go in the ladies room and i said
no i don't think it's you understands i
am the managing director
baroness brady she's one of britain's
most successful business women i'm the
kind of person that never hears the word
no i hear find another way to get what
you want leadership is about vision and
your art as a leader is to persuade
people to believe in your vision i
remember reading the story about your
son telling you on holiday and saying i
wish your blackberry would blow up
working mother is the best title for me
sometimes you don't get it right you can
only do the best you can do
ambition is that spark it's that fire
inside of yourself that won't let you
settle for anything other than what you
think you deserve and what you want what
you would say to those young women that
are starting out in their career
i would say
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
karen
hello stephen um i i've spent the last
couple of days listening to your
interviews and reading a lot of sort of
interviews you've done in newspapers and
things like that and as i got further
and further and further further into
your story and further into your
childhood there was this question which
i wasn't able to answer despite all that
i'd read and it's you clearly from a
very young age had this real
deep desire to have freedom which
resulted in this independence and also
resulted in this wonderful young person
who had this ability to like stand up
for themselves but where did this deep
desire to be free from the control of
others where does it come from
i don't know i mean my mother always
tells a story that um when i was four
that um
my grandfather was looking after me at
home and my parents had this drinks
cabinet and it was sort of opened down
and it had all these like bottles of
beautiful bottles and little glasses and
things
and she tells this story and i don't
remember it at all
but i got a chair and i climbed up and i
opened the drinks cabinet
and they had these little sherry glasses
and i poured all little bits of liquid
from it and i started to drink it and my
grandfather said um
don't do that you'll be sick and i said
you leave me alone i'll do what i want i
won't be sick and then of course drank a
half of
the drinks cabinet
um
and wasn't sick
and my mum said you were always defiant
you always
had your own mind wanted to do your own
thing
uh thought you knew best cut my own hair
when i was six we had a um a school
photo the next day
and i decided the only person who could
cut my hair was myself and you should
see the picture my fringe sort of starts
here and sort of goes like that and it's
got all lumps cut out of it i guess i
kind of thought if i didn't stand up for
myself no one would and i was very happy
to stand up for myself and
you know in life as you go through life
you one of the things you realize is
that if sometimes you've got to find
your backbone and you've got to use it
and simply putting one foot in front of
the other and keep going is one of the
philosophies i've had in my life but no
always define always
stood up for myself never took anything
lying down
yeah i don't know
defiant feels like the perfect word um
and i was trying to figure out where it
came from because usually when i sit
with my guests they can like even if
it's incorrect they can look back in
hindsight and pinpoint a moment some
kind of trauma or pain or negative
experience which shaped them to be a bit
of an anomaly in some way so i was like
where did this defiance come from and i
couldn't quite
figure it out i don't know i i have no
idea it's not part of any trauma that
happened to me i just
i guess i always felt
that i had something to say and even at
a young age i wanted to say it and i
didn't care
who heard it or how you know i just felt
i wanted to stand up for myself i have
no idea i've never really thought about
it
i know it's definitely a part of my
personality trait that
this defiance this i'm gonna prove
people wrong i'm going to do what i want
to do how i want to do it
but i never really thought about where
it came from
what's this story about your first day
of school and your mum being concerned
that you might be shy and finding out
that you shot some kid off the chair
well there's another story i mean i
don't remember any of these stories but
my mom said the first day of school she
was very worried if i would be shy or
would i want to go home or whatever and
she
went to pick me up from school and she
said to the teacher how was karen she
said oh your daughter's carrich should
always be shy she said karen shy she
said she she went up to a boy in a chair
and she went that's my seat get off
so but i don't remember it i don't
remember any of these things but all
these little stories they always have
one thing in common i have this sort of
level of defiance and this you know
determination to to stand up for myself
one of my suspicions when i was trying
to piece together this this little bit
of defiance puzzle was um reading about
your dad and how much of a sort of
hard-working
autonomous
man he was
and how hard you said he worked i was
wondering if they had given you a bit of
a kind of a void of independence when
you were growing up that
led you to create this kind of
independence in yourself was were they
like present and were they on you
no definitely not on me in that way they
weren't you know tiger parents pushing
you to the front although my grandmother
used to always say be first because it's
the best place to be she used to always
say that to me so my dad left school at
14 didn't have much of an education and
worked really hard to get where he
wanted and i guess the lesson from him
was you know nothing compensates for
hard work and if you don't try you know
if you don't try something you'll never
know how good you are at something so i
think maybe that
sheer resilience came from
his
model of
working hard doing your best trying
everything pushing yourself forward and
would he give you advice
would he impart knowledge onto you or
was it you learning by his
example of watching him work i think
almost definitely the the the second one
i i don't remember him ever sitting me
down and saying do this and you know
your life will be better or more
enriched i think it was just
learning from examples from
seeing the hard work and you know we
went from edmonton to a little bit
further up to another little place in
edmonton to a bit further up and our
lives sort of got slightly better and my
dad's desire was to give my brother and
i a really good education because he
hadn't had one so he really wanted us to
have
a great education because he felt that
was a big part of what was missing in
his life and i guess he maybe he thought
if you have a great education you don't
have to work so hard you don't have to
start so much at the bottom i think that
was a real driver for him
and your mother my mother was a
housewife
so she had no ambitions for work very
smart woman very nurturing in everything
that she did my dad was away working a
lot so she was a lot on her own
uh but equally fun loving and stylish
and you know
spoke her mind too
and you at this age didn't
have big ambitions for what you wanted
to do in the future in terms of specific
ambitions about career options there's a
quote which i read where you said i
wasn't gifted in anything i wasn't
academic i wasn't the best at anything
in fact i was a very average child who
really didn't know what she wanted to do
or where she was going to go the
greatest gift that my parents gave me
was self-esteem yeah
i think you're very lucky if you know
what you want to do
if you have a vocation or a calling at a
young age i think that is a remarkable
thing that you should
you should channel i didn't know what i
was good at i didn't feel i was
particularly good at anything it wasn't
as though i had a particular
panache for you know anything and
uh
i wasn't particularly ambitious but i
know i wanted to do something with my
life but i didn't know what and i think
ambition is something that sort of
creeps up on you slowly when you realize
you're good at something and you think
oh actually i'm quite good at this and
then you think actually i might be the
best person in this room at this or i
might be the best person i know at this
and that inspires you to
to keep going but i left school at 18 i
had no levels in a levels as they were
in those days but i had no
qualifications
but what i had worked has something
really important
and that is i'd worked out my core
values
so at 18 i had worked out that i was
ambitious
i was determined and i had integrity
and core values are the things that sort
of make you who you are they are the
things that lead you to make the
decisions you make for yourself and the
way you make decisions and 18 i knew
those things about myself and at 52 i
think they're still my core values and
armed with those things
i set out to get a job and this one
thing i wanted for my life was
independence i wanted to say what i
wanted to do and how i want to do it and
when i wanted to do it and that's
predominantly because i'd been at
boarding school for a very early age
going back to my father wanted to give
me the best education he thought
boarding school education was probably
the best and at boarding school you get
up when you're told you eat what you're
told you wear what you told you do what
you're told and i've had enough and i
knew that independence only really came
when you had your own money and the
problem is 18 i didn't know how you made
money but i kind of worked out almost
everyone works for someone even before
they work for themselves so i went out
and i got a job an a team with no
qualifications other than no levels and
a levels but armed with my core values
that i really wasn't afraid to work hard
and i was really ambitious and i would
try anything and i would do anything but
with integrity i went out and i got a
job and i started my career
something i just i was trying to piece
please um put two kind of dots together
there
boarding school a very restrictive place
the antithesis of like freedom your
childhood sounded like you had quite a
lot of
sort of relative freedom
is there is is it possible that you went
from a childhood pre-boarding school
where you had a bit more freedom and
then because boarding school was such a
big change
you had a bit of an allergic reaction to
the
someone taking your freedom or do you my
friends who are still my friends from
when we were at school in those days we
remember only one thing about that whole
time the boredom of simply being there
and having mass sort of three times a
day and the second thing was we were
hungry all the time every day was a fast
day so you'd have you know the holy
saint of such and such day and it was a
fast day and we remember those those two
things and the sort of repressive
attitude of wearing the same thing doing
the same thing doing what you're told
not being able to explore things you're
interested in
and
none of us could wait to none of us
could wait to leave but it did teach me
resilience
the ability
to do the things that need to be done
when they need to be done whether you
like it or not and that's because every
day was the same
and
there's a great
lesson i think in life in being able to
force yourself to do things you don't
want to do because you have to
and that taught me a great deal of
patience and resilience and
determination
which is funny because much of your
your life has been very much the
opposite doing making sure you don't
have to do things you don't want to do
and being like restricted by the rules
of others but there is a sense in every
job you do whether you're
a pop star you've got to sing the same
songs every night
you know whether you're working in an
office or working for someone else or
reporting to shelters there's an element
of our lives that has to be done
and you get that discipline from being
able to do it and power through it and
approaching it in the way it needs to be
approached which is a real discipline as
opposed to saying i don't want to do it
and i'm not going to do it there's a
difference
you said earlier about how you started
at one point to notice that the
advantages or the skills you had over
your peers at a maybe a young age around
maybe 18 when you start to join the
working world and before
what when you looked at say 18 19 year
old karen what were those skills that
you started to notice well i'm better
than
i seem to be better than everyone else
at this thing or you know stronger or
whatever i went into sales um which is
the sort of place where most people go
when they don't really have anything
else
they can do because
you you're either good at it or you're
not um but you don't need any particular
skills other than being able to have
resilience of picking up the phone keep
trying not taking the knock backs going
forward and i realized i was good at it
and i would never take no for an answer
i would always be determined i would
continue to pick up the phone i had a
sort of dogged attitude to not letting
the knocks get me down you know when
people slam the phone on you or they
don't want to speak that ability to
learn the language it wasn't do you want
any it was how many do you want you know
was that it was that sort of subtle
change of being able to be
personable i think i worked out an early
age that people do business with people
and it doesn't matter how much brain you
have if you don't have a personality you
can't put that brain into a good uh you
know in in into a good place so having a
personality and having a brain is a is a
good combination i worked in tele sales
as well for four years
from 16 to 20 or whatever it was and it
was
genuinely the most formative experience
of my life i agree also because i don't
have the qualifications so it's there
yeah yeah and it's a good place to start
i don't know about you but i'm not
particularly creative i couldn't have
done anything i mean i couldn't have
done anything in the arts world or
anything like that but actually picking
up the phone having that resilience
being prepared to take the knock backs
keep pushing forward never taking no for
an answer those are things i learned
from a very young young age so you did
sales at sanchez no i did uh menial
office work at sachitsarchi and i left
saatchi to go into sales at 19 and i
worked for london broadcasting company
where we sold advertising space and
that's where you met david sullivan yes
that's right yeah he was one of my very
first clients and he took radio
advertising and within
six months of me meeting him and selling
him radio advertising he was spending
two million pounds a year on radio which
was the highest
spender on commercial radio in the
country and i was on a really high
commission well done
it was a good time so you meet david
sullivan and he's quite
well he's not spending on radio at the
time when you met him and he's kind of
against it i hear yeah he didn't think
it particularly worked and i sold him
the idea that he would take the
advertising package and if sales didn't
go up he didn't have to pay for it
and he said yeah sounds okay to me and i
sort of thought well if he doesn't pay
for i'm going to be in trouble but i
thought i'd worry about that when that
happens i was just pleased to have made
the sale and he took the advertising the
advertising did work and he kept
spending and spending and spending if we
zoom in on that that sale that deal you
closed with david sullivan i know
a lot of people couldn't have closed
that deal and i know that was a pivotal
moment in your early career but i know a
lot of people couldn't have closed that
deal so as you look back in hindsight
what was it about karen that helped you
to close that deal well one i went to
see him so i turned up at his offices
and i waited until he saw me and i
waited a long time quite a few hours
until he felt i think sorry for me and i
wasn't going anywhere and he let me do
the pitch the presentation which i did
equally i always had this um feeling
that you know what's the worst that can
happen and the worst that could happen
is he didn't take the package and he
slung me out but the best that could
happen is he saw me and he took the
package so i always looked on the bright
side so i turned up i did the deal i
presented well i had all the facts and
figures i knew what i was talking about
and i guess he thought it took a chance
i think the package was i can't remember
it wasn't a lot of money and it wasn't a
multi-million pound deal that someone
had to really think about it i pitched
it just that it would be an impulse it
could be someone that it was enough
money to have a gamble not too much not
too little just in that spot and i
persuaded him i had this art of
persuasion
talked about what it could do for him
how it would work and he and he took it
and that was the beginning of my one of
my very own clients
that stayed with me for many years and
still today we're still working together
at west ham some 30 years later
that is pretty um incredible did he know
you were coming that day to pitch
he booked in a meeting to see you i
can't remember i think i'd booked in a
meeting whether he knew about that i
don't know
i can't remember because that did end up
being quite an early pivotal moment for
you it's quite a testament to the fact
that again people do buy from people and
that you were very a very persuasive
person but also there's a sub lesson in
there which i've heard you talk about
before which is when you're young and
you don't have a ton to lose because
young people fall into this trap of
thinking that
no is some kind of like death sentence
or it's fatal yeah but as you say you
know when you've got nothing else to
lose yeah i had nothing to lose the
worst thing that could happen is he
didn't buy it
and i had to sell it to someone i was
very independent i wasn't relying on my
parents for money i was relying on
myself i had no safety net no nest egg i
had no you know no i had to pay my rent
i had to pay my bills i had to pay my
travel i had to pay for my food and i
had to make that sale for me it had to
happen it wasn't a case of well we'll
we'll see
but
i'm the kind of person that never hears
the word no when someone says no to me i
don't hear no i hear find another way to
get what you want and that's what i
always do i always i think no it is is
only really pivotal if it ultimately
stops you
doing what you want to do if you hear no
and you can find another way of getting
what you want that's that's just as good
as hearing a yes am i right in thinking
that you're someone that like really
believes in a philosophy versus like
current skills because you're when you
talk you talk in terms of like your own
philosophy to life and a lot of people
when they speak they speak in terms of i
don't know skills or hacks or tricks
whatever but yours seems to be much
deeper than that even saying that
they're defaulting to optimism all the
time and uh
i don't know i've never really i've
never really thought about it
i think you you know you you you need
the ability to work hard you need the
ability to push yourself forward you
need the ability to have a backbone you
need the ability to um have a dogged
sort of determination and if you have a
great idea so much the better so much
the better people say to me you know
what what is an entrepreneur well an
entrepreneur is someone that just
spots a gap in the market for a service
or a product that that
is either
not available or available but they can
make it better and they're the kind of
people that well-meaning people say oh
don't do that that's very risky but they
are prepared to back themselves and put
all those doubters to one side and just
plow through it and that that's sort of
been what i've done for 30 years
as you said that relationship with david
has sustained still today and yeah he
actually went on to hire you so what
have you learned about the importance of
like relationship building in business
and i think that uh part and parcel of
running a great business is to have a
really good culture a really good
culture comes from trust and being
candid and being honest and
supporting one another and it's
interesting that david sullivan is i'm
is still
with me in west ham so is david gold two
people who i started with from a very
young age
um and we're still all working together
and we still have lots to talk about
lots of ideas and we still bounce off
each other and we trust each other and i
think that's a really fundamental part
of
growing a great business
being candid you said that
talk to me about how candid you are in
business
very i think it's important i have a
great
candid
atmosphere at west ham i want people to
say what they don't think is
right what they think could be better
what needs to be changed i think if you
have too many like-minded people running
the same organization you're so busy
passing each other off on the back as
you sort of follow each other off the
edge of the cliff you need people to say
hang on a minute why is this important
how does this affect us what does this
you know what does this mean we stand
for what are our values what's our
purpose you need people to be honest and
candid and i think candid is good and
how do i go about creating a candid
culture in my company say if i've you
know i'm running a business and i want
people to be more candid what what what
do i do and don't do to make sure that
we arrive at that place well the most
important thing the most important thing
that people want from you when you're
running your organization is your time
they want time with you they want you to
listen to them they want to
be in your inner circle they want to be
part of
part of it that's what people want um
it's you know it's become less i think
as
times have gone on about money and
status and more about
being in the know being in that
in that room when decisions are made and
making people feel that they can be in
the room that they're part of the
discussion and that you'll listen to
them and that they can say what they
want without
worrying about you know what's going to
happen to me next i think that's that's
really important so say someone's in the
board room with you and they they say
something which is maybe even negative
towards a decision you've made i guess
you've got to be cautious of your
reaction to make sure that they don't in
the future shy away from because you're
a very powerful woman you know it would
be quite intimidating to tell you the
truth i don't think i think if you spoke
to my staff they
or the people that i work with they
would all say
that the one thing karen is great at is
listening and understanding
and
i think the minute you think as a leader
of organization you know everything is
the minute you don't know anything at
all you have to believe in lifelong
learning you have to believe that the
people around you are valuable enough to
have a different opinion to yours that
is just as important and the minute you
think they they don't have an opinion
that's important as yours you either
don't have the right team or you don't
have the right team with the right
skills i like to employ people better
than me
because it sort of proves i'm better
than them if that makes sense and then
when you have people with
great knowledge and great skills why
wouldn't you listen to them when they
tell you something i mean of course you
have debates i want to do everything
quickly i want to do everything
with strength and power and purpose and
others are like oh hang on a minute
let's not go at that pace let's try and
do this let's do something and sometimes
you follow your gut instinct because
it's important and people say to me what
is a gut instinct a gut instinct i think
it's made up of all the experiences
you've had through your career
and
you've sort of when you're in face with
the problem you've been in that movie
before you've had that problem before
different problem in a different moment
about a different thing but very similar
and you know the outcome
so your gut instinct goes hang a minute
i've somehow i've been here before and i
know how this plays out and i find if i
follow my gut instinct i tend to go make
the right decisions and if i ignore it i
tend to go bad but
sometimes you need someone to go hang on
a minute take a step back have another
look at this have a think about this
and
it's a very uh it's a very lonely place
if you don't have people around you that
want the same things as you
that want to help you achieve and build
the things that you you want to do and
being able to listen to people and
encourage people to have their thoughts
and ideas is i think really really
important
so how much of an organization that you
you run and what parts of it are a
democracy because i'm trying to see that
balance between you being
assertive and making the call but also
operating in some respects like a bit of
a democracy where you're hearing
everyone's opinions is there like a
balancing
act yeah i mean look if you think about
leadership
and you should never confuse leadership
with management
management is about setting out a series
of goals and
managing people to deliver them very
important but that's not leadership
leadership is about vision
and sometimes it's only a vision you can
see
and your art as a leader is to persuade
people
to believe in your vision and help you
deliver it
so
we have
large groups of people that help deliver
visions
so our next vision for west ham for
example is to go from a sixty thousand
capacity to a sixty two and a half
thousand capacity and we're in the
process we've got planning permission
for it in the process of going through
that transition
um
how do we sell those extra tickets who
do we sell them to do we put the price
up where do we allocate them how do
people get in should there be more bars
these are huge decisions
one person cannot make those decisions
and everybody who has a stake in that
decision
should have a say
and that's everyone from the commercial
department right through to
you know the person who runs the
disabled supporters group everyone needs
to make that decision together and
that's how you breed great culture
listening to people understanding the
problems finding the solutions together
having some fun while you do it so it's
not all you know over charts and in in a
very um
rigid way it is much more in a
conversational way so for example i took
a load of my team to seville when we
played in europa and we went together we
had a great time together we used the
downtime to talk about things important
to us
and it's part and parcel of creating a
place where people feel really proud to
work
they feel really proud of what they do
and they feel really well respected
and they have a lot of fun have a lot of
fun yeah yeah
i just realized i'm playing at your
stadium
oh is it in the um the soccer age yes
yes
hopefully that will uh sell it out for
you but um no i just realized as you
were talking then yeah you're playing at
the unbelievable beautiful stadium
you're a big part of getting uh winning
the bid to kind of move over there on
the topic i'm really excited by the way
what a tremendous honor that is to get
to play at your stadium but um on the
topic of football then you so david
sullivan ends up hiring you from lbc yes
and you join his corporation yes and
then i hear it like 22 23 years old you
see an advert
in the financial times to for birmingham
city which is in financial hardship yes
and you've been in administration and
you persuaded david to buy yes
birmingham's
what
well he to be fair to him he was looking
at buying either a race course or a
football club he was interested in
doing something in that area
and
birmingham had gone into administration
there was a little ad that said football
club are saying i thought it was
interesting and i got the details and i
went to him i said this is football club
for sale you buy it and i'll run it what
and he was like whoa football very male
dominated you'll have to be twice as
good as the men to be so as even only
half as good and i said well luckily
that's not difficult
and he said okay we'll give it a go and
and we did and it was bought really
quickly within three days that was like
a friday and on the tuesday we owned the
club and that was it we
uh we went in there we we made so many
mistakes but we had a great time it was
such a fantastic experience you know to
be given the challenge and chance of a
lifetime to run a great business and
change it take it out of administration
i mean it made a trading profit for the
first time in its history and after my
first year and it was a real learning
curve
but it was great fun i love how you
glossed over the fact so
graciously that at 23 you took over the
management of a football club after
seeing an advert in the financial times
and persuading david dubai you took over
the management of a football club at 23
yes i was desperate to look at least 250
so
did you just have the the courage and
the conviction and the confidence to
take on that role because football is a
complete like i don't even think no i
definitely would not have the the
confidence to run a football club
and i i've loved football i've followed
it my whole life i've ran big businesses
but a football club is a whole different
beast it is like it is different and
it's different because
it doesn't make anything it doesn't
manufacture anything it doesn't produce
anything other than more footballers all
its assets are people
so being able to manage people
and to manage the diversity of those and
it comes back to that culture by having
an environment where everyone has to do
everything within their skill set to
make the business a success and know
that that is valued and respected and
there is no
uh
ceiling on your ambition whether it's 18
year old that wants to go into the first
team or the 18 year old who works in the
ticket office that one day wants to run
it it's up to you where you go and i
wanted to create a sort of a a business
that i wanted to work in when i was 18
where you
you was nothing holding you back there
was no politics there was no age there's
no discrimination whatsoever the it was
there for you
to do and achieve what you want to
achieve within our environment
and
that's why football is different because
some people can't get their heads around
the fact of what footballers earn and
they begrudge it if they're not playing
well they they don't you know part and
parcel of managing people is
understanding people and respecting
people and valuing people and giving
people your time and your encouragement
but more importantly than that
it's about standing
alongside people and supporting them
when things are not going well much more
than when things are going well um being
their backbone and their
uh and their support system
very important in people's business
as well as that culture what else was it
that helped you take birmingham because
your stint at birmingham is seen as
being incredibly successful as you say
like turn the club profitable for the
first time in like recent history
what how did you do that outside of
culture
there must have been tough decisions you
had to make they're very there were
loads i mean from when i first went
there to sort of getting rid of
everybody lots of businesses that i am
involved in or i know friends that run
the biggest
issue for lots of people that run those
businesses
is making the change to personnel when
they need to
because they find it very difficult if
someone's been with them a long time to
realize actually
that person's skill set was great when
we were growing the business and now we
need a different skill set to take it to
the next level but you think but that's
john john's been with us from it's very
difficult but you have to sort of step
above that and say it's my
responsibility to ensure this business
is a success for the 800 people that
work there and the shareholders and
everything it stands for so you have to
make the best decisions and you have to
try and remove as much emotion as you
can out of it but also always doing the
right thing for the right reason and not
for any other reason and i think one of
the most important things in a people
business is you must never underestimate
the power of kindness
being kind to people and being
respectful of people is really important
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast we often see
the success of a business and forget
about their humble beginnings and
vodafone who is one of the new sponsors
of my podcast is no exception to that in
fact
quite an inspiring story they started
above a curry shop in the center of
newbury in berkshire and that was the
year that they made the first ever
mobile phone call over 1g that was a
moment in history and they've continued
to innovate ever since they supported
the very first sms text over 2g and most
recently they've made history again this
time through 5g internet with the uk's
first holographic call but what i love
about vodafone business and one of the
reasons i partnered with them is they
want to enable others to go on the same
journey that they've been on with
innovation they have so much support to
help specifically small businesses
thrive their vhub site offers free
resources insights and expert one-on-one
sessions with vhub digital advisors so
you can access what's needed to embrace
innovation and drive your business
forward just by searching vhub for
vodafone on google and you can access
all of the support i've described above
the link is in the description below
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and my energy
as a sponsor of this podcast one of the
brands that make that transition much
much easier they are at the forefront of
british renewable ecosmart technology
and their products are really really
changing the game if you're on youtube
you can see what i'm holding in my hand
this is called the eddie right it's the
uk's number one solar powered diverter
so what is a solar diverter it's a
device for people like you and me that
means you can divert your excess energy
back into your home rather than back
into the grid which will save you power
and money it's super user friendly and
easy to install and you can control it
using the my energy app on your phone to
find out more about this product and
more products like it that will help you
make that sustainable transition head
over to myenergy.com and um i highly
recommend you check out the eddie it's
um it's a real game changer for a
product and one that i'm going to be
installing in my home soon
i think david sullivan and when he
described you and much the reason why he
had this has this huge admiration for
you is exactly that i think he in an
interview said you're a good
sucker i think what it probably meant
was i wasn't afraid to make tough
decisions yeah and and some of them were
really tough even at 23 yeah even at 23
i really had a clear vision of what i
wanted to achieve and
knew
the kind of people i needed around me to
achieve it
you talked about how emotion sometimes
gets in the way of those tough decisions
for a lot of people i've seen the same
thing in businesses when they get a
little bit romantic about
the wrong objective basically or the
wrong thing and that ends up
compromising what should be their
primary objective which is the company
you know in their role as ceo founder
whatever and i've also heard you say
that emotion
well maybe that was the headline of the
article you've described yourself as not
being an overly emotional person but the
article i read i remember the headline
was um emotion isn't in her makeup
so something's words to that effect does
that resonate with you is that something
do you think consider yourself to be an
emotional business person i'm very
logical as a person
i don't worry about
the effect on me of any decision that i
make as long as i feel it's the right
decision i worry about the effects it
has on others
um
but i'm i don't get overly emotional
about things to me which are unimportant
whether that be
criticism or social media or criticism
wherever that comes from as long as i
know the decision i've made and why i've
made that decision
i can stand by it and i care much more
about what my family and my friends and
my colleagues think of me than someone
on social media who i'm never going to
meet don't know
i'm never going to have a conversation
with so i'm not emotional from that
point of view when you take on a
football club as well and you've worked
in football clubs for what two decades
three decades three three decades now
you're dealing with emotional fan bases
just like
hysterical i i know because i'm a
manchester united fan and we're very you
know emotional as a fan base right now
but a hysterical almost unpleasable
thankless fan base it seems at times so
how has that impacted you the like the
voice of the fan base in your decision
making does it factor in
every decision i make i make for them
to make them prouder of the football
club
to bring them the success that they want
to deliver
the things they want to see at the
football club and the way they want to
see them
whether that's what we did through the
pandemic for our community what we
continue to do for our community the
fact that we keep our prices low the
fact that we promised them european
football and we've delivered it the fact
that we have great players and great
culture and a great manager every
every decision i make i don't make for
myself i make for them
and i do it to the very best of my
ability and sometimes they don't like
those decisions and sometimes they don't
agree with those decisions but
they're all done because it's what i
consider to be
for the best of the club
and also i guess sometimes they don't
understand those decisions because the
fan base isn't of any football club
isn't a fan base that's educated on
business and finance and the inner
workings of a club so there's lots of
like misconceptions about
the decisions that are being made and
are they like self-profiting decisions
or whatever
how important is transparency in running
i would say in any business but really
in a football club where you've got
millions of people who are your i guess
your stakeholders how and like clubs
don't seem to be that transparent
largely i think it's hugely important um
and i think i think football supporters
are very knowledgeable on the business
of football it may not be a priority for
them but i think they are knowledgeable
i mean they you've looked at clubs that
have had a really difficult financial
time and having a firm foundation on
which to build they know is important
and it's equally
you know
it's important that they know the
parameters i mean we we're not
you know
oligarchs or
saudi arabian billionaires we're we're
english taxpayers we do the best we can
and we generate as much money as we can
without putting that burden on to them
which is why we have the cheapest season
tickets in the premier league let alone
in london in a brand new stadium so we
try and
go on the journey together but i mean
moving to the olympic stadium
54 000 season ticket holders completely
sold out some people didn't like it but
you have to make a decision that you
think is right for the right reason and
going from a 35 000 cts stadium to a
what is going to be a 62 and a half
seater stadium
was a big move and a bold move and it
has proved to to work out for us which
is why we're now playing in europe what
would that have happened if we were up
to par probably not because it hadn't
happened
for many decades before that so
i think people don't like change and
it's important that they understand why
the change happens and
what it means to them and how it's going
to affect them and how hopefully it
enriches their life as opposed to make
it makes it worse do you have an
objective at west ham to um be
more transparent the recent event that
comes to mind around transparency in
football is obviously the
european super league thing where
suddenly one day we all wake up and all
of our favorite football clubs in the
like the top eight or whatever not even
in the top eight but had decided they
were all going to join top six yeah
they're not even the top yeah it wasn't
even the top six there were six of them
yeah exactly
i can't even say that manchester united
were at the point but um they decided to
join this this super league in europe
and it seemed like it was just this like
self-profiting decision which kind of
ruined football or whatever and after
that i saw a little bit of a change in
some clubs like liverpool that the
owners came out and did like a video
apologizing it was the first time i'd
seen like owners post a video of them
talking on social media is this one of
your objectives within the organization
that you run at west ham to be more open
and more of a glass box
we try to let our manager and our team
do the talking for us because
because
the the supporters don't want to hear
what the ceo thinks they want to know
what the team think and the manager
thinks and i think from our point of
view we're always very respectful of
that
you know some chairmen write program
notes some chairmans do videos we tend
to want our team to to do the talking
for us and we don't really want to put
any more pressure on them and the
manager than they all put on themselves
because they're the ones that put the
pressure on themselves to be successful
um they don't need it from us as i look
throughout your whole life one of the
clear consistent themes
in you is your hard work yeah it's just
like you know sometimes it looks a
little bit like obsession in certain
parts of your story i read about the
fridge not being turned on in your
apartment someone's saying my friend my
friend came to live with me and she said
um
the the sticky stuff still around the
fridge and the oven had never been
turned on and i yeah what age was that
21.
and you just you were working so hard
you hadn't turned the fridge on you were
in the office so much well the thought
of cooking and eating at home never
occurred to me i'd always grab something
on the way in or the way out would never
the thought of actually buying food
because i knew if i bought food it would
just go go off
people talk about work-life balance
right and this like obsessive like they
do these days yeah
when i was starting those that phrase
had never been uttered by anyone
what's your opinion of the the work-life
balance conversation oh i think it's uh
much more sensible than anything i did
definitely
i think that
you know in in my day you started at the
bottom of the run and you worked your
way up very slowly and carefully to get
as high up the ladder as you could
whereas now it feels much more like a
web where
you do a bit over here and a bit over
there and
change and do that and then don't like
that you go and do this
and you have a much more rounded life
and i think technology has changed how
we all work i mean you know you're
getting up at six o'clock in the morning
to be in the office at seven and staying
till eight o'clock at night you don't
have to do that now and i think that's
so much for the better so do you live a
more rounded life
definitely
yeah definitely i don't go into my
office at the crack of dawn and sit
there all day and expect everybody else
with the old ball and chain to be there
i mean i i know from having a family and
a career that actually having
flexibility is really important and
giving staff the ability to come in when
they need to and work from home when
they want to is important
but i guess you didn't always because i
remember you reading the story about
your son turning to you on holiday and
saying i wish your blackberry would blow
up mum or something yes working mother
is the best title for me because there's
two things that are very important in my
life and that is my family and my work
and i've tried my very best to to make
those things work together sometimes you
don't get it right sometimes you have to
decide that
family is more important than work or
work has a priority that's more
important than family and you have to
try and juggle and you spend your whole
life going sports day board meeting um
parents evening board meeting you know
you never know where you can be
and until you come to the conclusion
that you cannot
be in all the places you need to be you
you you can only do the best you can do
it's a sort of relief and sure my kids
will always say i worked throughout
their whole growing up
but they learn different things from a
working parent the ability to be
independent have
uh ambition to
value yourself to work hard those are
those are very good lessons as well and
you set aside time to like switch off
as they say i don't need to switch off
interesting i mean
nothing's work unless you'd rather be
doing something else i find and there
are times when i think oh god i got a
good go and do that like today
[Laughter]
but there are times like oh gotta go and
do that and you only feel that sort of
but the one thing
this drive for independence
it also comes with another added bonus
and that added bonus is the ability to
say no if i don't want to do anything
all i have to say is no no thank you
when you're building a career you have
to say yes to everything
and you have to say yes even when you so
want to say no and you say yes you think
how do i get out there so you're trying
to give a million
million things you know a million
excuses uh to get out of it but when you
are independent
you can say no and that it's a great
freedom to
not have any obligation where you have
to you don't have to say yes to anything
you could say no if you don't want to do
something and you say yes when you want
to do it and you tend to enjoy that
balance of your life a lot more we met
in saudi arabia for anybody that doesn't
know that was the first time we'd met
and i'd watched you on you know tv
growing up but in saudi arabia we're on
stage together we're in a panel of five
and
what happened on this stage i actually
came back and told my team and i said i
absolutely i love her right so i don't
know if you know what i'm about to say i
don't you don't okay so we're on stage
um in saudi arabia kind of like a
dragon's den style thing where these
entrepreneurs are coming up and pitching
to us and one of the panelists one of
the male panelists to my left
um you went to ask a question
right i don't know if you remember you
went to ask a question of the
entrepreneur that was pitching to us and
then one of the male panelists to my
left he kind of like interrupted you and
spoke and carried on speaking and you
waited about 30 seconds you let him
finish his kind of interruption
and then in front of what must have been
a thousand plus people you turned to him
very calmly said one second i asked my
question first and then you carried on
with your question and the whole
audience burst into applause
i do remember that do you remember
i do remember that and i'm sat there
like
do you remember that
i do remember that i was really quite
annoyed really um i was annoyed because
we'd gone to saudi well i'd gone to
saudi to talk about the importance of
women and our rights and being respected
and then to be
spoken over on a stage i was not going
to let that go under any circumstances
and i think it was a good way of being
able to show how it's important to stand
up for yourself and not to be
walked all over and i certainly was not
going to be walked all over and everyone
in the room understood that moment
the significance you described there
because it was in a very unemotional
professional way it wasn't in a it was
the most classy like wonderful
polite way
to destroy someone
[Laughter]
that's why i said to my team after i was
like she the way she did it was so like
classly classy and gracious but it made
such a profound point and you could tell
the point was made because the whole
room burst into applause
but that kind of brings me onto a wider
point about
and as you say the reason why you're in
saudi is this battle that i know you've
had through your career with men kind of
underestimating you or sexism which i
guess started when you first got the job
at birmingham
yeah i mean i remember my first um
away game i think it was watford
and i turned up and i saw hi could you
tell me where the boardroom is and this
little boy little steward on the desk he
went oh director's wives over there and
i saw this interesting but where where
is the boardroom
and he said dear you don't understand
the director's wives go in the ladies
room and i said no i don't think as you
understand i am the managing director so
i don't know where the boardroom is and
this little boy put his little glasses
on he went oh yes he said yes you're
that woman stay here and i'll find out
what to do with you because there were
no other women in football so there was
never a woman in the boardroom and women
weren't you know weren't welcome in
boardrooms because it was meant to be
the place where the directors all met
and of course they were all men
and i remember thinking
that it was the very first door i'd kick
down and i was determined that i would
keep that door open as wide and as long
as possible to get as many other women
through as possible and that is
something i've spent my last 30 years
doing it's really important to me it's
really important that that there is a
sense of equality and equal pay
and equal respect for everything that
you do regardless of where you're from
what sex you are what your beliefs are
how you look where you're educated
equality is very important to me why do
you think it's so important to you in
particular
i think because look at 23 i was given
the challenge and chance of a lifetime
and i took that and i knew that that
started with someone having trust in me
and
i knew that there were so many talented
people out there that didn't have
someone that had that trust in them and
i wanted to be that person
did you experience um
sort of sexist behavior from the players
occasionally but
nothing that i couldn't deal with i mean
i was very lucky in a sense
that from 16 to 18 i went to a
boarding school that was predominantly
all boys so i had girls in the six forms
he had like i don't know 20 girls and
600 boys so being surrounded with
young men all had something to say and
knowing how to deal with that was
something that stood me in good good
stead for my career so it wasn't
difficult for me and i didn't get phased
by it and it didn't upset me and i
wasn't emotionally damaged and i didn't
feel scared i'd if i had to go crying to
anyone i i i could deal with it it
didn't phase me and it was an
irrelevance of mine one of the things
that i've noticed specifically in the
like black community is or one of the
concerns i had growing up was i'd seen
some of my black friends that the belief
that they were they were at a
disadvantage actually seemed to hurt
them more than the disadvantage itself
if that makes sense
do you have the same concern that
worrying too much that you might not get
in will stop you from taking the actions
to get in if that makes sense
i'm sure every
every woman at some point in their
career when they've had to say shall i
stop to have a family
what is that going to you know how is
that going to affect me how is that
going to affect my pay my career
prospects my promotion my standing i'm
sure every woman at that point has had
that that thought and unfortunately or
fortunately as we
you know women give birth to
all the taxpayers in the world we
deserve a break really so i'm sure it is
a thought that crosses people's mind i
mean i read some research that 54 000
returning
new mothers to work so badly treated
because they are considered to be
a burden to the teams in which they work
people are going to think they're going
to want to go early they're not going to
be as focused they're going to have
brain fog that they are either hounded
out of their jobs or choose to leave and
that's a shocking statistic
so yeah i can see how people
are just you know waiting for that
moment when someone you know when you do
have to say
might have to go and pick my son up from
school i have to leave early it's a
difficult conversation and you're
considered to be
you know less valuable because you have
these these these real other issues so i
i can understand how it plays on
people's mind but it's important for
women like me
to change attitudes because if i don't
do if women like me who
achieve something if we don't use our
voice to change it for the next
generation who's gonna do it
one of my guests pointed out to me um a
couple of weeks ago that when a woman is
successful
and she's a mother people always ask the
question like oh my god how do you how
do you do it whereas when a guy is
successful even if he's a father no one
no one cares about no no one asks no one
asks because they presume he's got a
wife yeah he's doing it for him
yeah like joe wicks
joe wix has been here once or twice and
when joe wicks is doing all of his stuff
p4j etc no one is on his instagram going
what about the kids yeah
but um we've had women entrepreneurs
that have been here who do a very very
similar thing to joe wicks and it's the
question that they get asked all over
their instagram if they do a workout on
their social media it's like well where
are the kids but i think there's two
reasons for that
one is other women want to know how do
you manage that so you can inspire me to
to to find a way
um and the other is because it's uh it's
an easy thing to ask a woman and that's
the lazy question you know where your
kids what do you do with your kids how
do you manage with your kids it's a bit
like when whenever
you know whenever there's a picture of a
woman
there's always what she's wearing yeah
uh where is never for a man maybe
because women wear better clothes
but it's always about what you're
wearing where'd you get it how much was
it
um and it's always defined you you know
uh
so and so in her bright pink jacket they
don't say oh stephen and his blacks i
wish they did
[Laughter]
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as the seasons
have begun to change so how's my diet
and um
right now i'm just going to be
completely honest with you i'm starting
to think a lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 percent
of the time so i track it with 10 of my
friends in a whatsapp group and this
tracker online that we all use together
we call it fitness blockchain and i'm
currently at 81 percent um so 81 of the
days i've done a workout in the last 150
days right so i'm going to the gym about
six times a week
that's been a little bit impacted by the
derivative live tour but i'm trying to
stick to it and so one of the things i'm
doing now to reduce my calorie intake
and trying to get back to being
nutritionally complete and all i eat is
i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
paul
your husband paul
been together since 1995. i think you
met him at birmingham yes he was like
the star player how's that been you know
being such a
career-driven person
um who's had these
fairly all-consuming jobs throughout the
years
you know it's funny when i there's an
interesting thing that happens in the
comments section when i because i ask
every single guest every single podcast
about relationships it's something i'm
just really intrigued by because i've
struggled over the years with my work
and trying to balance the relationship
but when i ask women this people again i
understand why they assume that i'm
asking it because for the same reasons
we've just described like i'm trying to
understand how you can be a wife but
also hard working so i just want to put
that out there because i see it
but i'm really curious you know you've
been this pretty relentless entrepreneur
for the last three decades whatever it's
been
how has it been to to manage a
relationship and be that person um and a
partner while also being the tremendous
businessman well um you have to remember
that we've been married a very long time
and
when we first got together paul's career
was much more dominant than mine really
and uh he was traveling around playing
at different clubs playing for his
country and i was the one staying at
home looking after the kids having my
career and and working around that and
he was the one going around and then he
uh retired from football and my career
took off a bit and then he became a
football manager and i stayed home more
with the kids and we sort of we've
balanced our our lives to give each
other the space to do the things that we
love that make us rounded individuals i
have no
jealousy of anything he does and equally
to me so for example when i'm filming
the apprentice um i don't know how it
how it works on dragon's den but when we
film the apprentice when it says it's 4
am the voice over says it's for him it
really is 4 a.m
and we work
16 to 18 hours a day seven days a week
for five weeks to produce that show
without a break there isn't a day off
and it is really hard going
so i always say to paul it's much better
if he's not there
because i want to get up at four o'clock
in the morning have a bath put the
lights on turn the television on
leave when i want then get back maybe
eight o'clock at night go straight to
bed ready for
a four a.m start the following day or
whatever it is so he goes to canada to
see his family because his parents live
in canada and he has a great time with
his family and i can focus on what i
have to do without any distractions
because what happens during that period
is let's say he might say um
she'll go out for dinner tonight and
i'll say yes and then
i don't get home because filming's
overrun and i'm not home to one o'clock
in the morning and then he's like oh
you're coming you're not coming like i
just it's too much it's on the top of
everything else it's too much it's much
better if i have my space to do what
i've got to do and he has the space to
do what he's got to do
but the one thing that we have in common
is we've built a great family and we
we respect each other we love our kids
our kids are our whole life even though
they are you know 25 and 23 we
everything is about our family and
everything we do together is is really
important and
i have to say if you said to me you got
one day left on the earth would you do
with it i'd want to spend it with my
husband and my two kids because we have
such a great laugh together and we're
good friends and
there's a real
bond of
family between us how important is it to
be canned because that's kind of what
you were describing there being so
candid with how you're feeling and what
you're going through a lot of people
don't have that in relationships we're
definitely candid
we're definitely counted and how
important is that do you think i'm
asking for myself i think it's really
important because
you can't
pretend to be someone you're not
it's a bit like in an early part of a
relationship i've got a friend who's
have got an early part of a relationship
and the guy she is with
likes the opera she cannot stand it
but she say oh yes love the opera and
i'm like why don't you say hate the
opera i couldn't think of anything i'd
rather do less because when he finds out
actually hate the opera and then or all
you find out you've got to go more to
the opera and you're going to resent it
why not just be honest from the start
sir i really can't stand the opera you
go you have a nice time let me know what
it's like i think it's probably our
relationship is not needy
so
he doesn't need me i don't need him we
want to be together but we don't need to
be together i don't need to know where
he is every minute of the day i don't
need to know what his thoughts are on
every single thing or everything i do i
think if he could have me a little bit
more needy probably would but he knows
that i'm very self-sufficient and
don't need
much from anyone um
and i think that's again going from
boarding school where you're very much
on your own you'd like your own company
but we we don't we don't there's not a
neediness in the relationship where
uh i say to him oh i've been invited to
go
um
to to buckingham palace for um dinner
with the queen and it's white so i'm not
going to that i'm not a white tie no i'm
not getting a white town and he won't
come like he's not if he doesn't want to
come to anything he won't come uh and
i'll say oh i've got this you know thing
do you fancy doing that he'll say no
definitely not or he'll say
should we i fancy doing this and i'll
say no i don't do that so we we very
candid with each other and it works for
us
this is the single biggest mistake i
made at the start of my relationship i
mean my girlfriend had a conversation
and we discussed it was i was
saying yes too much to things to try and
please because you feel like that's
what's needed whereas
i came to learn over the years and i've
literally had this conversation with my
girlfriend over the last month that in
fact i need to just be honest more
regardless of how i think it might
impact us because you see you're saying
yes when you really want to say no yeah
and then you've got this sort of
underlying resentment and it's much
better to just say no and suffer the
consequences
yeah definitely versus forever because
as you say with the opera i then have to
try and live out this life right now
exactly exactly and i think it's
important to have your own space and
your own friends and do your own thing
um you know you're married but you're
not joined at the hip
and there's of course there has to be a
level of mutual respect there and and
honesty and trust and all of those
things that goes without saying but
you're not the same person and it is
okay to have different interests and it
is okay my husband is a gym bunnies
professional athlete he's at the gym
morning noon and night i could not think
of anything i'd rather do less as you
can see i'm not a gym bunny i don't go
to the gym i've got no desire to go to
the gym
this is i'm going to the um yeah bye and
that's it uh and i say i'm going to a
board meeting like yeah bye now he can
think of anything he'd rather do less
but it's
we respect each other's space and views
and ideas and we don't have to debate
every last thing or every last decision
um
and everything's okay like
we we don't worry about anything we
don't say don't worry about anything we
don't sweat about stuff
uh you know i don't care if he doesn't
pick up his socks
interesting
the whole world is not going to stop
because they've picked up his socks
but i tell you what really is important
in a relationship
is understanding
when other people are under pressure
and being there for them and i don't
mean being in
there with them but i mean just being
there for them and doing the things that
really matter to them
as opposed to big romantic gestures
i can't i mean i'm not a flower person i
don't particularly like flowers if
someone bought me flowers it's okay but
i'm not a big law i don't need flowers
but
my husband used to fill my car at a
petrol
so it was one less thing i had to
worry about
and it's small things like that that
build a foundation
because you know that person's there for
you even though it's not a big romantic
gesture that the whole world can see
because that's really not very important
to me have you ever done the love
languages test thing
no i don't even know what it is so i'm
not into this kind of woo i think thing
but this is actually quite from just 17
magazine or something i don't even know
it's a series of questions which try to
understand how the the type of
love indicator that you most appreciate
and it tends to be the case that busy
entrepreneurial people their their love
language is and as is mine is acts of
service and it's exactly what you've
described the tiny little thing to help
in a moment so like helping you pack
your luggage when they know you're
traveling yeah or just doing that tiny
and for me when i did i did the survey
with my girlfriend i'll send it to you
mine was acts of service for me the most
meaningful thing someone can do for me
in a relationship is exactly what you
said it's like yeah help me with a tiny
thing that you know yeah but it's his
sort of love language per se the same
some people says like touch words of
affirmation
acts of service oh gifts is one of them
i think you take any of the above
does he get it
yes he does no we we uh i think for us
the most important thing for us is
having a laugh having lots of family and
friends that we enjoy their company with
and
you know it's interesting lots of
couples have been married a long time
they need lots of people around them to
break up
you know
they have lots of friends over lots of
do lots of things big parties and stuff
like that though the one thing he does
for me every day without fail
is he takes the dog for a walk which is
very important and he picks up a coffee
and he brings it straight to me and that
because he knows i cannot start my day
without without a coffee and that's his
big love moment every day is there a
need to maintain desire when you're sort
of two almost three decades into your
relationship is there things to do is
there a strategy to keep it this is the
wrong podcast
[Laughter]
date nights i don't know is there
something that i should be thinking
about when i get through well i think
from our point of view our kids are
grown-ups every night's a date night for
us but i think doing things that are
different and unusual i mean we went on
this fantastic tour of thailand where we
went all over did really
crazy wonderful things that were really
good fun so we'd try and do more
experience-led things but equally we are
you know we are prepared to go in our
track suits and go out to the pub um i
mean our i guess our happy place if i
have to think about happy place is soho
farmhouse that's a real happy place for
us and we tend to try and go one weekend
a month
um and we spend two nights and really
don't do anything take the dog on long
walks have loads to drink watch a film
go out to eat lots of food just
relax
one thing you've never i've never seen
you talk about from from all that i read
is mental health your own mental health
this is kind of a
fairly new conversation that's happened
in the last 10 years
but have you had experiences with things
like anxiety or depression within your
own mental health no i haven't
maybe i have but i just haven't focused
on it or haven't really thought about it
i think we all have bad days don't we
where we're we're sort of more snappy
than than others and days were really
good i started hrt recently and i found
myself singing in the kitchen the other
day which is something i don't think
i've ever done and i was like chris this
stuff's working
so but no i have this resilience from
this you know from my very early age to
be able to
put things to one side and focus on what
needs to be done and not really worry
too much about it which is probably both
a blessing and a curse and you do you
describe yourself i was reading one of
your books do you describe yourself as a
feminist
definitely yeah and what does that mean
to you to me it means equality it
doesn't mean
wanting more than men it doesn't mean
disliking men it just means
that women's rights should be equal to
men's
it has been stigmatized hasn't it that
the word feminism is this kind of like i
feel like it's become a little bit of a
well the stigma is it's kind of this
anti-man
rhetoric whereas really i think men
should be feel like they're feminists
too definitely every every man has a
mother um has an aunt has a sister has a
cousin has a female in his life that
should want them to be treated equally i
mean it's a it's a truth for every pound
a man makes one makes 86 p and it's
gonna take a hundred years to close that
gap and if you get into industries like
finance
you know that gap is is much bigger than
that so it's just about equality it's
about not being discriminated against
because you're a woman not being paid
less because you're a woman not
being able to earn your worth because
you're a woman that's what it means to
me and as we look forward at the future
you've achieved so so much in your life
in your career it seems like from what
you because you said earlier on that you
weren't ambitious but young it seems
like you've probably surpassed your
childhood early years ambitions already
is that accurate i'd already put words
in your mouth but is that accurate yeah
i would think so yeah so what what's
what's driving you now what's the
thing flipping the duvet and getting you
out of bed if you've surpassed all those
ambitions i mean the toughest thing
about being a success is you've got to
keep on being a success
there's no point in having a successful
year last year to do nothing this year
and what drives that
is ambition and i
really am disappointed when people are
afraid to say they're ambitious because
we tend to think ambitious people are
ruthless people and that's not the case
ambition is that spark it's that fire
inside of yourself that won't let you
settle for anything other than what you
think you deserve and what you want and
uh
i love what i do i feel so proud that i
run west ham i feel so proud that i'm in
the house of laws and the work that's
important there that has to be done
um i love the businesses that i'm
involved in the charities that i'm
involved in i've picked the things i
wanted because i wanted to say yes to
them and i don't have anything i
secretly wanted to say no but say yes so
um
i think a sort of all-rounded life
whether it's doing the apprentice
something i love is such good fun i mean
we're there i don't know how it is on
your show but on my show there's a real
level of support and we're all good
friends i mean alan claude and i are
going holiday together we go out for
dinner we we're friends we're firm
friends first and and and foremost and
i love what i do and i just want to keep
doing it
is there a goal or an ambition for you
or is it more of the same is that the
do you have like when you think okay 10
years from now i've never had that i've
never set milestones
i mean i did have when i was younger i
had a flat and i wanted a flat that had
heating and then i wanted a flat that
had heating and a washing machine
and then i wanted to flat the head
heating and a washing machine and a car
so i did have those sort of milestones
as opposed to ambitions but i don't have
any of that anymore it's nothing i want
i don't ever look at people and think oh
i wish i had that or i really want one
of those i actually don't want anything
i don't have a car i don't need a car i
like to walk i don't have a lot of stuff
um i'm not uh
my some people i know have
wardrobes the size of your flap with so
many clothes in i buy a load of clothes
for the apprentice and i give them all
away to dress for success or to my staff
when i'm finished i don't have a lot of
stuff and i've never wanted a lot of
things so i don't have this sort of oh i
must get a boat or a yacht i mean i'd
never want anything like that i love
what i do i'm very happy in my life i'm
very content i wake up every morning
without anxiety i never feel i've bitten
off more than i can chew i never think
how am i gonna see through the day that
is ahead of me i'm never thinking about
how i pay my bills i'm never thinking
about how do i keep up with the joneses
i'm never worrying about those things
that weighs a lot of people down and
give them a lot of issues i'm very happy
i'm very content i've lived a full life
they say you only live once
but i think if you live it right once is
probably enough
amen
i'm reflecting on 19 18 19 year old
karen that starts at saatchi and and
then the person that sat in front of me
today
and i'm wondering
based on that full life and that
experience you've had and all those
boardrooms and experiences you've had
what you would say
to a 90 because there's going to be i
know that you know on
several platforms the majority of our
listeners are female
what you would say to those young women
that are starting out in their career
what would you whisper in their ears
they're on their monday morning walks
today and i see them uploading this on
their stories what would you say to them
in terms of navigating their future
i would say grasp every opportunity
try as hard as you can
never be afraid to fail
and
i was going to swear but i won't swear
please we swear every day
and stand up for yourself and and trust
me you do not want to get to 52 and look
back on your life and say i wish i would
have you will always regret the things
you don't do more than the things that
you do
so
go and do stuff
thank you it's been honestly such a huge
honor and pleasure to speak to you
because yeah i was in my team now i've
had this like weird captivated crush on
you ever since i saw you in saudi arabia
because of that strength and that your
wisdom your strength and your and all
you've achieved in your life and it's
it's very very inspiring and interesting
to
especially the path you've walked in
such a male dominated industry and how
how you you've you've forged your own
success at just like 22 years old that
real pivotal moment where you take over
a football club
utterly fascinating and um
yeah and we have a closing tradition on
this podcast where the previous guest
writes a question for the next guest oh
goodness you could have told me i could
have said something really really
this is the question that's been left
for you by oh okay a certain individual
okay interesting when you walk out of
here after this beautiful conversation
with stephen
i didn't write this
after this beautiful conversation with
stephen do you feel enriched and if so
what would you say to the next person
you meet
on your experience
i would say
that
sometimes it's
very difficult to
decide to share your story
because you open yourself up and
people get to know you in a way that
maybe
you never thought they would
but actually
sharing your story
you hope inspires someone else
and it also gives you the opportunity to
look back and reflect on your own life
because many of us are so busy moving
forward that we stop to say
oh [ __ ] yeah i was 19 once what was i
doing when i was living in that horrible
apartment with no washing machine and no
heating and when i didn't have a car and
how i worried about paying my bills it's
it's easy when you're 52 to forget who
you were at 18. and it's opportunities
like this when you think about your life
and the journey that you've been on that
you can
you know
surprise yourself
and you don't do many interviews do you
i don't i'm i'd steal well clearly
because i think it's time for other
women to speak
i think that you know it's like i could
take a whole load of non-execs and i
could take valuable positions that other
women could have i've had my time i'm 52
i've been there i've done all that i
don't want to appear in okay magazine i
don't you know want to
be posing in a swimsuit or any of those
things none of that appeals to me i want
to lead a
calm
incident-free
quiet life
um
inspiring others in all in a way i can i
want nothing for myself out of this
other than i hope that people have have
enjoyed it
i certainly
believe they would have thank you so
much karen for your time today and thank
you for your wisdom you're such a classy
grace great graceful inspiring human
being and yeah you've inspired me in so
many ways not just from watching you
growing up on the apprentice but also in
saudi arabia and again today so i'm i
have a debt of gratitude that i owe to
you and thank you for being here thank
you so much for having me
[Music]
you